eww
[musique]
ben j'habite près d'ici
Table des matières
Vu que ça a toujours été là, c'est comme ça
C'est ma première fois, donc je suis un peu surpris
juste rapide
Quels seraient les dégâts
Hey, il y a des rumeurs qui font référence à ceci et cela.
C'est trop diversifié, donc je n'aimais pas 10 personnes
maintenant nous
Notre chambre est aussi au-delà du problème en soi
Maintenant le bureau de district puis le bureau de district
Allez 1er et contactez gt
J'ai eu ce genre de dommage il y a 11 ans.
prendre des mesures
plus
[musique]
Ah, la quantité de précipitations par heure
Meilleure observation météorologique en Corée
changement climatique record
Il provient de l'article 4 ci-dessus
Il est jugé être
Le gouvernement est responsable du changement climatique
Le fait que le temps anormal soit devenu une routine
Compte tenu du système actuel de gestion des catastrophes
doit être revu à partir de zéro